Yo tout le monde, c'est Squeezie
Aujourd'hui on se retrouve sur Douchbag's Chick.
J'ai beaucoup de mal à dire ça...
Un jeu dans lequel on va jouer une fille
qui veut avoir des grosses fesses, des énormes seins,
des jolis pieds avec des escarpins,
et un visage d'une beauté inegalée.
Start game! C'est parti dites-nous les secr.. Ohhh on vient de loin !
Premièrement on doit trouver un métier.
Attends.. cette fille elle n'est pas mieux que.. celle qu'on a vu sur l'écran d’accueil quand même ?
Je dis ça, je dis rien.
Par contre pour le vert ça non, ça non j'suis désolé.
Y'a quand même euh... faut pas déconner.
Allez on va trouver un taf mon gars !
C'est pas tout mais on veut être BG ! Ok on prend l'bus
Beauty care shopping..? Non mais j'veux juste trouver un travail
Bon ben.. beauty care.
Merde mais j'ai pas du tout trouvé un travail là... Ohhh c'est quoi çaaa ?!
Est-ce qu'on a vraiment envie d'être comme elle ?
"Breast implant", tout de suite... pff
Non mais mec, arrêtez vos conneries arrêtez vos conneries, déjà on va travailler.
C'est où pour trouver un travail ? Ahh mais sur l'ordi, le con...
Le con j'ai mis 20$ dans un bus pour rien faire, putain.
20$ c'est quoi ? C'est des pièces sur les sourcils mon gars.
Allez on trouve un travail ! On peut être caissier, ou alors serveuse..
Serveuse avec les pourboires ! C'est un bon plan, ça!
Ah merde faut être jolie, on peut pas.
Et caissière ? Caissière on peut. Attends, n'importe quoi... moi des fois je vois des caissières qui sont très jolies, euh voilà.
"Your job starts at 8.00 tomorrow", OK ça marche. Du coup aujourd'hui j'fais quoi?
Rien ? J'ai rien à faire. Est-que j'peux avoir des amis ?
Allez on va s'ajouter des amis mec, voilà !
Oh noon ! On a partagé un truc sur twitter c'est :"Oh mon dieu cet acné me ruine la vie.."
Je sais ce que c'est, gamine.
Mais ça finit toujours par s'en aller, alors on ne on ne peut.... J'ai du mal à parler.
Alors on arrête d’être négatif, voilà.
Ecoutez on va juste dormir et on va aller bosser demain.
OK on est debout c'est parti on va aller au putain de super marché.
WOHOW, faites péter ! +96$ mon gars
Du coup on va faire quoi ? On va euuuuh... Aller au beauty care.
Voir la meuf aux seins qui reposent sur la table.
Dans une bache en plastique...? *rires*
"Make up upgrade" OK. Ahhhhh !
C'est bien ça ! On va aussi se refaire les cheveux.. *pouffe*
Et on va aussi se refaire.. Ahh la chirurgie, ça coûte extrêmement cher.
OK liposuccion....WAW!
Attends mais mec on est d'accord, on a juste un maquillage dégueulasse qui se voit totalement ?
Ils ont mal fait le contour des yeux !
Allez on va au travail ! Gagner de l'argent c'est cool, on va aller faire du shopping un peu.
Qu'est-ce qu'on peut s'acheter là ? Un p'tit haut... oh bah pff, attends j'ai jamais vu ça c'est quoi ?
C'est un semi décol...Vous avez déjà vu ça ?!
... N'achetez pas ça. *rires*
Franchement niveau chaussures ça va y'a pas besoin.
Qu'est-ce qui nous manquerait là ? Une p'tite jupe. Allez la bonne jupe léopard de cougar. Booom!
Ça va pas du tout ensemble, on s'en fout.
OH mon dieu on va faire une fête. Ça coûte 20$ on pourra toujours travailler sauf que... Oohhh on fait une fête mec.
OH mon dieu on va faire une une chir. PARTY ROCK!
"Zéro fuck friends".... oh j'ai eu des bisous ! Ouiii !
Attends mec on dirait totalement une SDF (en riant) avec ce bidou qui dépasse, ce truc a moitié déchiré, c'est trop bizarre.
Allez on va travailler, on va "work work work work work"
Qu'est-ce qu'on peut se faire ? "Tanning upgrade" c'est quoi ?
Ohhh mon dieu on s'est fait des UV ! Maaah !
OH ! Pourquoi cette biatch est chez moi ?
Est-ce qu'elle peut travailler pour moi ? On veut exploiter nos potes c'est horrible.
Allez on dort. Putain les gars notre vie c'est dormir, travailler, dormir, travailler..
J'en peux plus, j'en peux plus de cette vie. Regardez on dort, on se lève,
... on va biper des packs de lait et puis on va revenir dormir... Là, je....
J'ai.. j'ai besoin, j'ai besoin de mes implants, j'ai besoin... j'ai besoin d-de... d'être très très maigre.
J'ai besoin d'avoir un cul énorme ! Je... je SATURE !!!!
Aujourd'hui est un nouveau jour. HILTON, BOOM !
+20 000$ !!! Ah merde, j'ai cassé ce cable...
(Musique)
"Go to work", je m'en bats les c***lles !
J'ai hérité de 20 000$ mon gars !
Qu'est-ce qu'on va faire ? On va aller au centre de beauté. On va faire quoi ? On va.. Ah des implants c'est très bien.
Oui j'veux qu'ils soient gros, j'veux qu'ils soient ENORMES ! ENCORE ! OUI !!! *rires*
Oh oui des lèvres énormes ! J'veux que quand j'fasse la bise à quelqu'un il ait carrément un suçon après. AH OUI !
Là je suis trop grosse, je suis trop grosse, j'veux maigrir. OUI, maigrir, AHHH OUI !
Ahh les cheveux, c'est quoi cette coupe ? Bah ouais moi j'veux le blond platine.
Là on dirait une SDF qui a hérité et..qui a fait n'importe quoi.
"Tanning" : on veut être plus bronzée qu'un black, voil... *pouffe de rire*
Attends-tends-tends... qu'est-ce que c'est cette tenue là, faut qu'on fasse du shopping mec !
*rires* C'est quoi ça ?! C'est quoi ce haut mec ?!
Non mais mec, c'est n'importe quoi. Ces vêtements n'existent pas.
Qu'est-ce qu'on a en jupe là ? Bah ça, tiens. Pourquoi cacher tes fesses quand tu veux que les gens les regardent ?
C'est vrai, c'est vrai !
Oh bah pff ! Que dis-je, mais que dis-je ? C'est totalement normal de se balader comme ça !
Et là vous savez ce qu'on va faire là ?On va rentrer à la maison. Et qu'est-ce qu'on va faire ? On va faire la FÊTE ! BITCH !
(Musique)
OK on se calme le soleil se lève...
Avec qui on a fait l'amour cette nuit ?
... On n'est plus puceau !!!
Opopop on va changer de métier à un moment.. on va devenir.. une super star ?
Ah non faut coucher avec 250 mecs, pardon.
Pour être une star faut coucher avec 200 mecs, hein, faites attention à ça.
C'est vrai que c'est très important. Les mecs c'est pareil, si vous voulez devenir une star, va falloir coucher avec des gens.
Du coup on a couché avec une seule personne, du coup on peut faire quoi ? Bah rien.
On va devoir faire des fêtes, de plus en plus de fêtes.
Ah on a pas tout c'est pour ça ! ... Mon dieu ! On pas acheté les derniers Louboutins ! Ahhh ça va mieux. *soupir*
Oh oui, oh oui ça fait du bien, oh là j'suis bien là, oh là j'suis bien là... Oh la dernière c'est...C'est mieux là.
Oh non, le dernier jogging Adidas putain... C'est bon on a tout, on a 91% de trucs matériels. Pourquoi 91% ? J'ai tout acheté... !
OH MON DIEU ! Les derniers escarpins qui sont sortis au moment où je suis sortie de la boutique j'avais pas vu. OH... *soupirs* Oulaaa...
C'est bon on a tout. On va pouvoir se changer et mettre la tenue la plus biatch possible.
Pour attirer le plus d'hommes possible tout droit dans nos fesses ce soir.
Voila ça ça devrait être bien, en plus ils verront que je suis une fille bien et que je ne couche pas le premier soir.
Comme ça c'est parfait, allez on va faire la fête,  on va faire la fête mon gars. Faut qu'on baise, on veut devenir une star.
C'est le moment de faire la meilleure fête de cette ville !
(Musique)
OK c'est la fin de cette soirée, avec combien d'hommes avons-nous  couché ? ... 5 ! WOOOHH ! Putaaain, elle fait pas semblant !
Nouvelles demandes d'amis, 14 hommes qui veulent coucher avec moi, c'est incroyable.
Qui parlerait à une fille comme ça pour son physique ?
Ça se voit que c'est une meuf bien et ça ce voit que c'est pas le genre de meuf à coucher le premier soir.
Huit... on fait l'amour avec 8 hommes au total, en seulement 4 nuits. Et la première nuit c'était notre première fois.
271 amis mon gars, là on commence à faire des fêtes ! Pfou, on entend parler de moi.
(Musique)
On s'est fait sept mecs cette nuit les gars, SEPT MECS !
OH mon dieu toujours plus de filles chez moi c'est incroyabl..*rires*.
Putain j'ai mal au doigt tellement je dois accepter de nombreuses demandes, c'est incroyable. Ahhh, c'est dur d'être... une pute.
C'est l'heure de faire une fête. (musique)
Combien d'hommes, combien d'hommes, combien d'hommes....?
OOOH.....12 !
ALLEZ-Y PETEZ-MOI LE CUL !! Je deviens mannequin !
Putain mais ça s'arrête jamais, je passe mes journées à accepter des demandes d'amis.
Mais c'est pour devenir une star alors ça vaut le coup.
Des miliers de dollars dépensés dans des fêtes, beaucoup d'hommes dans son lit, encore plus de gens qui branlent rien dans le salon
Nous sommes enfin devenus une star. Et on a mal a cul tellement...*rires*.
Voilà j'vais pas vous mentir, euh.. on est une star. Allez on va travailler on a gagné 800....On bosse qu'une heure et on touche 1000$ ?
Putain sympa d'être une star hein ! Ben voilà, bah du coup maintenant euh... ma vie c'est de la merde.
Et voilà hommes et filles c'est déjà la fin de cette vidéo sur "Douchebag's Chick" ! N'hésitez pas à l'aimer si elle vous a plu.
Tout ça pour dire les filles, peu importe votre physique, peu importe vos complexes ou quoi... aimez-vous comme vous êtes.
Ne cherchez pas à avoir les seins plus gros, ne cherchez pas à avoir un énorme cul,
ne cherchez pas à avoir tellement de maquillage sur la gueule qu'on voit même plus un millimètre carré de votre vraie peau.
Vous êtes très jolies comme vous êtes, vous n'avez pas besoin de toute cette merde.
Ça marche pas, bah ouais.
Franchement tout ca c'est des futilités, ayez confiance en vous et ne vous laissez pas influancer
.. parce que sur les affiches c'est toujours des meufs extrêmement maigres qu'on voit,
qui ont des seins comme ça, un cul comme ça... ce sont des aliens, ça n'existe pas, D'ACCORD ?
Allez c'est la conclusion de cette vidéo, c'est beau, c'est beau, euh... petite musique romantique. À très vite !
(Musique)